how to promote online trading to
stimulate growth it's one of the topics
for discussion at the competitiveness
Council in Brussels on 28 and 29 of May
ministers will discuss a new strategy
for the e used digital single market for
example French people should be able to
buy books from a German online retailer
and Spanish should have access to movies
in Belgium ministers will explore ways
to move forward with the digital
transformation of the economy to ensure
that the European Union does not fall
behind in the Internet age the council
will also try to reach political
agreement on the reform of package
travel rules these packages typically
include transport hotel and some other
services such as a car hire the current
rules which dates back to nineteen
ninety offer protection to consumers
book in all inclusive holidays from
brochures the proposed reform would
extend this protection to online
bookings of all inclusive travel
services finally ministers will discuss
product safety in particular the issue
of a mandatory indication of origin for
non-food products sold in the European
Union